[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
continue this morning with the uptick in
book bans playing out in public schools
across this country
according to pen america from july of
2021 through march of 2022 there were
nearly 1600 actions taken in school
districts to ban more than 1100 titles
that's defined as when a previously
accessible book becomes either
completely removed from availability to
students or where access to a book is
restricted or diminished because of its
content the american library association
adds that the challenges often target
books that mirror the lives of those who
are gay queer or transgender or that
tell the stories of persons who are
black indigenous or persons of color
while a cbs news poll found a majority
of americans are opposed to school book
bans we found out the fight over what's
allowed in public school libraries and
classrooms is another example in this
election year of just how divided we
truly are as a country
are you aware of indian boarding schools
they call themselves the teen band book
club and every week this summer they
gathered at the firefly bookstore in
kutztown pennsylvania to talk about them
it's like the cherry on top why on this
day sherman alex sees the absolutely
true diary of a part-time indian was the
topic it was only when he got older he
realized just one of the novels that
frequently makes the american library
association's list of most challenged
books you don't really see much actual
native american history that isn't
like claire's like sugar coated 9th
grader jocelyn diffenbaugh founded the
group what got into you to start a book
club on banned books when i first
started seeing all the books being
banned especially in states like texas
where they'd come out with a very very
long list i hadn't seen anything wrong
or that wouldn't need them to be
challenged have you had a hard time
finding books you want to read jocelyn's
mother lisa says the real turning point
came when it appeared their local school
board might be facing the same debate as
with our last school board election we
started getting mailers about
why to elect these certain people to the
school board and in there they had the
book um i am jazz and they said this is
what they're teaching your children they
want them to be transgender and our
school didn't even own the book she read
this flyer and she said mom like what
they're using a book to rile people up
to give them a vote it's they're using
this book as a weapon i don't understand
i can't get a straight answer from
anybody who chooses these books as
efforts to ban books have risen
nationwide school board meetings have
become increasingly contentious i think
they should be thrown in a fire people
see him university of pennsylvania
professor dan hopkins studies the
nationalization of state and local
politics we use a lot of fervor around
possibly banning books is just the
latest instance of national politics
coming home and deep symbolic divisions
that national politics bring
um playing out in our schools and in our
communities and they're trickling down
to the books our children read yeah
absolutely you can get involved in your
local community you can take your your
passions and your commitments in
national politics and you can bring them
into local politics you can bring them
to a school board meeting we are angry
and we know our rights enjoy the time we
have it was that spirit of activism and
anger over school coveted restrictions
that led tiffany justice to co-found
moms for liberty the group championed by
conservatives funding advocates for
greater parental rights accountability
and transparency in schools parents are
the best and first teachers of our
children as moms for liberty is swelled
to more than 85 thousand members with
chapters in 42 states some chapters have
pushed to ban or limit access to books
in school libraries this issue around
books has has become a lightning rod
it's a distraction i mean there's not
two sides to this issue there are moms
who love their kids who don't want
pornography in school and then there are
people who do want pornography in school
i think that the book issue has been
used to try to marginalize and vilify
parents and the truth is there is no
place for pornography in public schools
that's a lightning rod of a term yeah
it's pornography
yeah we don't put penthouse and hustler
and playboy into public school libraries
and the books that have been removed
in indian river county for example where
i'm from
have been books that provide no
educational content there's no value to
them our moms are horrified it's
shocking when the moms come to the
school board and they try to read a book
that has such graphic depictions of
sexual violence and their mic is cut off
excuse yes excuse me yes we have
children at home don't you find the
irony in that but then it's placed back
on a a public school library shelf our
moms are not political this is something
that i think has been assumed and is
really wrong a lot of our moms have
never really been involved in the
political process at all it feels like a
runway honestly it feels like a runway
leading up to the next election author
jason reynolds is the national
ambassador for young people's literature
imagine growing up not being able to
read the diary of frank or not being
able to experience beloved he's seen
several of his own books banned
including stamped racism anti-racism and
you and all american boys a novel about
two teens experiences with racism and
police brutality if you're writing about
race if you're writing about sex and
gender
then you want to chop them black what is
the most effective challenge to these
books obscenity so so the interesting
thing is that everyone thinks that the
challenge that the most effective
challenge is the book has racial topics
that make my children uncomfortable
right so this is sort of what we're
using to talk about because it's the one
that's being pushed to the forefront but
the truth of the matter is is that most
of these books are
challenged based on obscenity which is
an excuse to not have to say it's
because they're a racial topic so they
are sexual topics in these books and so
what happens is that we we produce this
work young people read it the adults are
uncomfortable and so they assume that
their young people are uncomfortable the
real question is why is discomfort a bad
thing is being uncomfortable the same as
being unsafe the answer is no give
perhaps no author has had their work
challenged more than margaret atwood
author of the handmaid's tale i'm too
old to be that shocked surprised or
horrified
because i've seen it for those folks out
there
parents in particular who say
they deserve a right
to say what's going on in the education
of their young people everybody deserves
a right to say anything they wish as
long as it's true that's the real
question
but part of a democracy is parents
having a say
they can have a say they don't
necessarily have the right to dictate
but to say they can't have a say
that's pretty authoritarian isn't it
what the parents were were saying was
that they didn't want uh hitler's race
theory taught in schools you'd probably
say hooray for them but at its core is
access and all the potential that can be
lost but we all need to have that
freedom to parent our kids the way we
want so it's fine if you don't want your
kid reading the hate u give or even
harry potter but you need to manage that
within your own family and with your own
kids but don't take away every kid's
read and every parent's ability to
manage other kids read every book is for
everybody but
every book is for someone it might not
be for her and it might not be for my
family it might not be for most kids but
there is one kid who might one student
who might need to read that book and
it's there for them
we should note that the moms for liberty
chapter in indian river county florida
challenged more than 150 books last year
ultimately five of them were removed
from school libraries now the list
includes the novel gone girl and the
graphic novel blankets
we wanted to show you some titles that
are still heavily challenged nationwide
according to the american library
association they include of mice and men
to kill a mockingbird books from the
captain underpants series and even the
odyssey so this is a
far-reaching uh situation in our country
all across the country and not every
state is banning the same types of books
or the same subjects but it is creeping
in
far-reaching in a timeless debate about
what people should read and whether some
people shouldn't read certain things
right where the control is can you
control it at home versus trying to
dictate to others in the schools